bonjour à tous alors une première
question est-ce que vous nous voyez ce
que vous nous entendez bien n'hésitez
pas à répondre sur le chat
donc je vais donc introduire cette
conférence donc je m'appelle Marielle m
je travaille à la chambre de métier de
l'artisanat et je vous remercie de
participer à la cinquième édition de ma
journée découverte des métiers
organisé donc par la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat en partenariat avec la
faculté des VTT des zones le CFA du
bâtiment et celui des Apprentis
d'Auteuil les cinq web conférences que
nous proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de la Semaine nationale de
l'apprentissage sont consacrés à
l'orientation des jeunes vers des
métiers de l'automobile du coup de la
fleuristerie du bâtiment et de la beauté
ce sont les métiers qui font partie de
la grande famille de l'artisanat avant
de commencer notre web conférence
j'aimerais vous faire part de quelques
éléments de contexte aujourd'hui
l'artisanat français est un secteur qui
a le vent en poupe un million 830 000
entreprises artisanales ont été recensés
en juin 2022 aujourd'hui un créateur
d'entreprise sur 4 est un artisan ce qui
atteste du dynamisme de ce secteur
quête de sens valorisation du fabriqué
en France recherche d'épanouissement
professionnel et personnel toutes ces
valeurs poussent aussi bien les jeunes
que les personnes reconversion
professionnelle vers l'artisanat
porteur d'un nouveau modèle économique
la preuve 178 000 apprentis ont été
formés dans l'artisanat en 2021 un
record inégalé l'apprentissage fait donc
partie intégrante de l'ADN de
l'artisanat sachez que la formation par
la voie de l'apprentissage offre de
belles opportunités d'avenir puisque 80%
des apprentis sont en emploi dans les
six mois qui suivent leur formation
l'apprentissage vous permet également de
devenir entrepreneur en effet plus de la
moitié des dirigeants actuels ont été
eux-mêmes apprentis
voilà de quoi alimenter nos discussions
et surtout nous espérons que cet
événement suscitera des vocations
place maintenant à la présentation de la
filière de la beauté et du bien-être
autour de la table nous accueillons
madame Sandrine Salut bonjour
mademoiselle Lilou
usco bonjour
que je précise madame Sandrine Sahu et
formatrice en coiffure et Lilou est
apprenti en mission complémentaire
mention complémentaire pardon de
coiffure madame Dalila kennedyle bonjour
à tous formatrice en esthétique et
Mademoiselle Manon Duclos esthétique
et Madame Virginie faux
responsable de filière bonjour à tous
nous allons commencer
cette présentation alors donc je vais
commencer cette présentation donc je
suis la responsable de filière
des métiers de la beauté et du bien-être
donc je suis accompagné de formatrice en
coiffure et en esthétique et de jeunes
filles qui sont en apprentissage dans
ces métiers là alors déjà
l'apprentissage
ça prend vraiment tout son sens pour
justement ces métiers là ces métiers de
l'artisanat de l'esthétique de la
coiffure il faut savoir que être en
apprentissage ça vous permet de suivre
une formation et en même temps d'être
chez un employeur donc en fait être en
apprentissage c'est être salarié en
formation professionnelle
et puis ça vous permet bien évidemment
de pouvoir passer un diplôme il faut
savoir que sur effectivement ces
formations nous avons une forte demande
des employeurs et ça vous permet de
pratiquer beaucoup d'autres métiers
votre futur métier tout en pouvant
passer votre diplôme
donc par rapport aux statut de
l'apprentissage peut-être pouvons-nous
passer à la à la slide suivante vous
allez pouvoir voir justement un petit
peu ce que ça veut dire être apprenti et
puis surtout les conditions la
législation la matière donc pour être en
contrat d'apprentissage vous devez avoir
entre 15 et 29 ans révoluent
la formation vous la suivez
obligatoirement effectivement au CFA
donc il faut savoir que en fait vous
allez vous allez signer un contrat
d'apprentissage
de 35 heures et que dans ces 35 heures
vous êtes et au CFA donc et en formation
et en entreprise et nous l'alternance
dans notre CFA et en particulier sur ces
métiers là c'est pour une somme presque
toutes les formations mais je vais me
retourner vers les formatrices c'est
toute la journée en fait du 2 jours 3
jours donc les jeunes sont et en
entreprise et au CFA toutes les semaines
donc ça permet finalement de pas avoir
entre l'entreprise et puis et puis la
formation ce qui est quand même plutôt
plutôt plus adapté et aussi c'est ce que
préfère souvent les entreprises donc
voilà il faut savoir qu'effectivement ce
temps de formation en tout cas fait
partie de votre votre de votre contrat
de travail de votre statut et la
rémunération elle est fonction de deux
choses elle est fonction de votre âge et
de votre année de formation donc vous
avez aussi sur la slide suivante
justement les rémunérations les niveaux
de rémunération donc là je dois
l'apprenti c'est entre 15 ans et 17 ans
en fait jusqu'à la majorité par exemple
en première année de contrat et ben la
rémunération est à 27% du SMIC voilà
pour prendre un exemple il faut savoir
que les rémunérations tous les niveaux
de rémunération que vous pouvez avoir
sur un contrat d'apprentissage sont
marqués sur le contrat donc vous les
connaissez à la signature du contrat
d'accord et si jamais pendant le cas de
votre contrat d'apprentissage le niveau
du SMIC votre rémunération augmentera
par rapport à ce niveau là puisque c'est
un pourcentage du centre
voilà un petit peu sur le sur le contrat
d'apprentissage peut-être que je peux
vous dire de plus c'est qu'il y a une
période d'essai cette période d'essai
elle est de 45 jours effectivement en
entreprise donc pendant cette période-là
c'est soit vous soit l'employeur il est
possible de rompre le contrat à tout
moment une fois que la période d'essai
est passée
si jamais effectivement il devait y
avoir une rupture de contrat c'est une
rupture à l'amiable effectivement et là
il ne faut pas hésiter voilà en parler
et à mettre absolument dans la boucle
chimie c'est chargé de développement
qui discutera avec vous
d'éventuelles difficultés si ça devait
s'il devait être nécessaire de rendre le
contrat
voilà un petit peu pour la partie légale
maintenant
on va vous proposer un petit quiz
que vous devez voir donc sur votre écran
combien d'apprentis trouve un contrat à
durée indéterminée après leurs études
donc on vous laisse on vous laisse
choisir le nombre 20% 80% ou 50%
alors vous avez tous répondu
50% j'attends un petit peu
en fait c'est mieux c'est mieux puisque
80% ah voilà certains ont mis 80 % vous
avez raison en fait on a un excellent
taux de
contrat de à durée indéterminée après un
apprentissage
près de la moitié en fait des élèves
restent au sein de l'entreprise dans
lequel ils ont eu leur formation mais
80%
des apprentis pour un CDI dans les six
mois qui qui suivent leurs études
on va vous présenter maintenant
un film dans lequel vous allez découvrir
les métiers de la beauté et du bien-être
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation d'alternance du sud-francilien
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
c'est 90 formations gratuites et
rémunérées du CAP au Bac + 5 dans 8
filières métiers réparties sur trois
sites
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et 5000 stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussis et de réelles
opportunités d'emplois en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
sur le site d'Evry Courcouronnes la
filière beauté bien-être propose des
formations en coiffure et en esthétique
d'anciens apprentis aujourd'hui salariés
ou chefs d'entreprise et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience j'ai choisi l'alternance
parce que pour moi c'est une liberté
autant financièrement parlant que même
au niveau de la pratique on peut exercer
beaucoup plus facilement notre métier
quand on est allé à l'école et un salon
c'est vraiment le plus du CFA on apprend
mieux on est plus sur le terrain on
devient plus mature c'est pas évident de
trouver des bons professeurs qui
prennent leur métier à cœur et si j'ai
eu de la chance d'en trouver ils aiment
ce qu'ils font ils ont vraiment envie
que leurs élèves réussissent dans les
moments où j'avais des doutes au niveau
de mon orientation je savais pas trop
quel chemin emprunter j'ai toujours pu
me confier à des profs qui m'ont
vraiment aidé et conforté dans mes choix
c'est un bel endroit les professeurs
sont très gentils il vous épaule
jusqu'au bout il vous aide et c'est très
agréable de venir apprendre ici on a
tous les équipements professionnels les
casques les bonnes coiffages les bacs
donc c'est vraiment tout comme un salon
de coiffure mais pour l'apprentissage
j'ai envie de transmettre mon
savoir-faire à mes apprentis pour
qu'elle puisse évoluer les faire grandir
à leur tour j'ai gardé de très bon
contact avec ma professeur de pratique
je fais des petites interventions pour
parler de mon parcours professionnel
avec ses élèves donc c'est j'aime
beaucoup
si tu es de pas de la gare RER et
organisée autour d'espaces verts arboré
le campus d'Évry de la Faculté des
Métiers de l'Essonne propose des
équipements dédiés modernes et
performants deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'application ouvert au
public sur réservation un centre de
ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition self et cafétéria
enfin la Faculté des Métiers de
l'Essonne dispose d'un service d'accès à
l'alternance proposant notamment une
prépa apprentissage et permettant à la
faculté des métiers des sols d'être
fiers d'intégrer tout type de handicap
alors n'hésitez pas rejoignez-nous
nous allons nous allons reprendre donc
la présentation du CFA
de la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
pour vous présenter rapidement le CFA
donc on est le plus gros CFA dans les
murs d'Île-de-France on accueille près
3000 apprentis sur trois sites
finalement alors Évry qui est le plus
gros site avait près avec près de 2000
un peu plus de 2250 apprenants et puis
c'est sur ce site là effectivement que
nous avons les métiers de l'artisanat et
notamment les métiers beauté bien-être
ainsi ta Massy qui comprend en fait la
plupart des formations que nous
proposons en tertiaire on a à peu près
500 apprenants et puis un autre site sur
Bondoufle avec les métiers de
l'industrie avec près de 250 apprenants
donc je vais laisser la parole justement
à mes à mes collègues pour présenter les
métiers de la coiffure et de
l'esthétique comme je vous laisse la
parole
donc moi je suis Madame salut donc prof
de coiffure
j'enseigne le cap bébé
pour la coiffure on se verra tous les 15
jours 7h d'affilée
une partie le matin où on fait de la
technologie
la technologie c'est quoi c'est de
connaître les produits les shampoings
pourquoi je fais tel état shampoing sur
le client
les toutes les coloration
les compositions de produits donc ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la technologie et
après on passe donc en pratique sur des
têtes Malia avec différentes coupes
puisqu'on verra toutes les coupes
qui existent plus les colorations les
permanentes pour tout ce qui est brevet
professionnel après on verra des choses
un petit peu plus approfondie mais déjà
en CAP voilà ce qu'on peut voir il faut
savoir que
le cap l'épreuve du Cap est quand même
importante puisque dans cette épreuve
vous allez avoir une
coloration à faire sur votre modèle
c'est sur des vrais modèles
une permanente à l'eau une coupe
brushing et une coupe homme voilà au
niveau du matériel évidemment on nous
sommes obligés de travailler il faut
avoir quand même une petite valise cette
valise comporte ce qu'on appelle le
petit matériel le petit matériel ça va
être la paire de ciseaux les bigoudis
séchoir et une autre valise qui va
comporter le livre pivot point c'est un
livre avec lequel vous pouvez
revoir les coupes avec un petit cœur
code qui vous permet de visualiser toute
la vidéo qu'on verra en cours donc c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez refaire ou
au salon ou à la maison
donc ce matériel la somme de ce matériel
fait à peu près entre 730 et 750 euros
avec une aide donc de l'état de 500
euros voilà pour tout ce qui est au
niveau de la coiffure là je vais laisser
la place à ma collègue en élastiques
donc rebonjour à tous moi c'est Valérie
je suis formatrice en pratique
esthétique et en cosmétologie donc au
sein du CFA nous proposons trois
diplômes différents donc le cap
esthétique et le diplôme de base pour
accéder en tout cas au métier
d'esthéticienne ou d'esthéticien on peut
le passer en deux ans ou un an si on a
déjà une formation ensuite nous
proposons le BP Esthétique et un niveau
bac et enfin le BTS qui impacte plus 2
donc j'enseigne pour les CAP les bébés
et anciennement j'ai pratiqué aussi pour
les BTS donc je suis spécialisé en
brevet professionnel pour tout ce qui
est diplôme donc le cap c'est le diplôme
de base comme je disais tout à l'heure
donc on enchaîne principalement les
épilations les soins du les soins des
mains et des pieds aussi tout ce qui est
maquillage des ongles comme le vernis
classique et le vernis semi permanent et
enfin le maquillage du visage tout ce
qui est basique un maquillage marié jour
soir et enfin pour le bébé qui donc plus
spécialisé aujourd'hui ce sont les
attentes en tout cas de des entreprises
on se spécialise en soins du visage
aussi en soins du corps tout ce qui est
massage à partir relaxation etc et puis
tout ce qui est prothésionulaire la base
toujours parce qu'il y a des formations
aussi à faire après après l'entreprise
et puis après les après l'école et le
maquillage aussi et pour le BTS c'est un
mix entre le Cap et bébé pour la
pratique mais c'est surtout pour des
attentes comme par exemple on a envie de
se spécialiser on a envie d'être
informatrice professeur c'est pas
manager ou des ambitions encore plus
grandes
alors vous avez pu voir un petit quiz
donc l'apprentissage est réservé aux
élèves qui ne peuvent pas continuer des
études en enseignement général qui ne
sont pas motivés pour continuer les
études
vous avez répondu 25 % vrai 75 % faux
vous avez raison dans votre majorité
puisque en fait
l'apprentissage n'est absolument pas
réservé aux élèves qui ne peuvent pas
continuer des études
par contre il faut aimer le métier
finalement que l'on va pratiquer pendant
sa carrière professionnelle donc c'est
plutôt
le gouffre de ce métier l'envie de faire
ce métier et la connaissance technique
de ces métiers qui vont vous permettre
de réussir votre votre vie
professionnelle
donc
nous vous proposons maintenant
quelques conseils pour mener à bien
votre future vie d'apprenti si vous
soyez si vous choisissez cette cette
manière de faire vos études
alors bonjour à tous je suis Cécile Gary
médiatrice de l'apprentissage à la
Chambre des Métiers du 91 et
effectivement on va essayer ensemble de
de
[Musique]
voilà d'aborder trois points qui
pourraient être clé pour pour bien
amorcer votre votre apprentissage
alors je vous rassure tout de suite la
plupart du temps tout se passe très très
bien
mais effectivement voilà les trois
points qui reviennent qui reviennent
régulièrement donc le premier point
c'est de montrer sa motivation alors
c'est assez large comme comme point mais
ça englobe pas mal de choses par exemple
arriver à l'heure c'est tout bête mais
effectivement c'est des choses qui sont
qui sont importantes il faut bien vous
mettre en tête que vous êtes salarié qui
dit salarié du coup vous faites partie
d'une équipe chaque minute compte
puisque vous êtes payé souvent ça fait
la différence j'essaye de vous donner
des mots qui peuvent
qui peuvent évoquer des choses
positives donc voilà ça c'est très
important montrer sa motivation ça fait
voilà arriver alors ça fait partie de
de sa motivation
ne pas hésiter à effectivement
retourner voir son maître
d'apprentissage ou sa maître
d'apprentissage pour éventuellement
dire voilà j'ai fini j'ai fini cette
tâche là ne pas tourner en rond je sais
que c'est difficile et enfin je viens on
l'entend très bien vous êtes très jeune
c'est effectivement
passé outre sa timidité comment comment
je viens pour enfin tout vous paraît un
peu insurmontable sur les premières
années et c'est bien normal attendez
voilà tout ça vient vient avec l'âge et
on a tous été pareil donc surtout voilà
ça ne pourra jamais vous être reproché
de revenir voir votre maître
d'apprentissage pour dire ce que je fais
est-ce que du coup ce que j'ai fait
c'est bien voilà est-ce que est-ce que
je peux faire autre chose ça ça montre
effectivement que vous êtes pas
spectateur de ce qui se passe là en
l'occurrence dans le salon
et voilà essayez de vraiment
demander une autre tâche et tout ça
ensuite
le deuxième point c'est se passer de son
téléphone portable alors ça c'est un ça
c'est quelque chose de critique mais en
même temps qu'on peut comprendre parce
qu'effectivement c'est des choses encore
une fois
vous êtes né avec donc ça vous paraît
hyper compliqué de vous passer c'est
comme une troisième main et on peut pas
voilà effectivement on peut pas on peut
pas vous le reprocher mais en même temps
il faut vraiment vous mettre dans la
situation que encore une fois vous êtes
salarié et vous apprenez en plus à un
métier donc surtout il va falloir du
coup le portable effectivement ça vous
empêche forcément de d'être complètement
à fond et puis en plus ça ne se fait pas
donc quand on est salarié c'est comme un
peu à l'école on laisse un peu son
portable de côté
vous aurez des pauses vous pourrez le
retrouver
sans problème mais surtout faire
attention à ça donc les TikTok les snaps
pendant que vous bossez s'il vous plaît
non en fait on va éviter
et puis et puis voilà et puis quand vous
allez retrouver votre portable vous
aurez plein de notifications des
messages ça fait une satisfaction
personnelle géniale voilà c'est vraiment
croyez moi sur parole mais vraiment
voilà faites attention là-dessus c'est
quelque chose qui revient
malheureusement
assez assez régulièrement sur les
conflits et qui peuvent qui peuvent être
facilement éviter voilà et le troisième
point c'est solliciter des échanges avec
le maître d'apprentissage
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
effectivement moi j'encourage vraiment à
nouer le dialogue avec son maître
d'apprentissage
sur les conflits que je peux rencontrer
effectivement le manque de communication
c'est la malheureusement c'est la
première la première des causes donc
effectivement moi ce que j'aime bien ce
que j'aime bien vous conseiller c'est je
sais pas après effectivement là c'était
trois jours de jours mais effectivement
ça peut être une semaine une semaine ou
voilà c'est effectivement avant de
retourner à l'école une fois que vous
avez fini sur les derniers jours
d'entreprise ben voilà de faire un petit
point même si c'est 5 minutes et je suis
bien contient que les mettre
d'apprentissage ont plein de choses à
faire sur donc concrets on va être on va
parler français le concret c'est très
compliqué de trouver du temps pour
essayer de se poser et faire toute une
réunion non sincèrement je sais que ça
va pas être possible maintenant vous
posez juste cinq minutes pour essayer de
dire bah voilà faire un point juste
qu'est-ce que j'ai moi moins bien fait
qu'est-ce que sur quoi j'ai réussi ben
voilà ça ça devient un point à amélioré
ça il y a un point effectivement où
c'est super et il faut que tu continues
comme ça ça c'est des choses où
effectivement où en gros ne pas laisser
traîner les choses qui ne vont pas en
fait pour pas que du coup on rentre
après dans des situations
conflictuelles qui sont beaucoup plus
compliquées à gérer en plus pour des
choses clairement qui sont
facilement gérables à la base donc voilà
vraiment vous encourager à faire ce
petit ce petit point
avant chaque retour à l'école je pense
que ça peut ça peut aider à nouer un
dialogue à nouer un
[Musique]
à nouer à instaurer un climat de
confiance avec son maître
d'apprentissage je pense que c'est très
important
voilà merci beaucoup Cécile pour ces
trois ces trois conseils de bon sens
mais il faut toujours mieux peut-être
les préciser
sa vie de tout jeune salarié en tant
qu'apprenti on va passer maintenant donc
à des informations pratiques pour
l'inscription que vous pouvez faire
un centre de formation d'apprentis
alors effectivement on en concernant la
procédure d'inscription il faut savoir
que vous pouvez dès à présent vous
préinscrire donc c'est sur notre site où
là vous voyez il y a un QR code là qui
est sur l'écran donc vous retrouvez de
toute façon toutes ces informations sur
notre site notre site internet
donc vous vous pré inscrivez en ligne et
puis ensuite vous aurez voilà la
procédure à suivre vous recevrez un mail
surtout être faites attention à vos
spams ça peut être dans les spams mais
voilà dès que vous vous inscrivez en
ligne vous recevrez de toute façon en
mail
n'hésitez pas si jamais vous n'en
receviez pas au bout de on va dire
attendez quelques jours n'hésitez pas à
faire un mail vous avez toutes les
coordonnées de toute façon sur le site
de la Faculté des Métiers vous avez vous
allez sur la filière beauté bien-être
inscription et tout est indiqué vous
pouvez également bien évidemment venir
nous rencontrer lors de nos porte
ouverte donc je vous encourage vivement
à venir visiter
donc éventuellement avec vos parents
pour ceux qui seraient encore mineurs
venir visiter nos locaux rencontrer les
formatrices les formateurs l'équipe
encadrantes et puis surtout visualiser
les ateliers voir là où vous aurez vous
aurez cours et puis voilà rencontré
l'ensemble des formateurs qui répondront
aussi à vos questions
donc voilà vous avez les dates les dates
qui s'affichent donc avec une porte une
porte ouverte par mois jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
et puis voilà là vous avez les
coordonnées des personnes qui s'occupent
des inscriptions des inscriptions donc
monsieur mzeali pour l'esthétique et
Madame Boussa pour pour la coiffure et
surtout la chargée de développement qui
va vous aider pour votre recherche
d'entreprise donc Isabelle Fournol et
avec laquelle vous pourrez échanger soit
au moment de votre préinscription soit
après dans l'accompagnement pour la
recherche d'entreprise puisque nous
aidons nous aidons les jeunes qui
n'auraient pas encore de patrons à
chercher une entreprise néanmoins si
vous êtes déjà intéressé n'attendez pas
de nous rencontrer pour cela vous pouvez
déjà commencer à chercher une entreprise
on a aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui
arrivent qui ont cherché une entreprise
et qui arrivent avec leur entreprise
puisque encore une fois ce sont des
métiers qui fonctionnent énormément avec
de l'apprentissage donc énormément
d'entreprises prennent des apprentis que
ce soit en esthétique ou en coiffure
donc n'hésitez pas déjà à les solliciter
voilà n'attendez pas
alors comme vous pouvez le voir c'est à
vous maintenant nous sommes là pour
répondre à vos questions donc n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions dans le sur le
chat en attendant vos questions donc on
va
laisser la parole à nos jeunes à nos
jeunes apprentis qui ont eu la
gentillesse de venir vous voir et vous
répondre aujourd'hui donc Lilou et Manon
donc toutes les deux on va peut-être
commencer par faire une tour si tu veux
bien
qu'est-ce qui t'a amené donc à choisir
ce métier par la par la voix de
l'apprentissage alors moi j'ai commencé
la coiffure grâce à ma mère parce
qu'elle était coiffeuse avant du coup
j'ai toujours été dedans du coup j'ai
voulu m'a tenter moi mon tour et du coup
bah j'ai passé mon CAP là maintenant je
suis un morceau complémentaire et bah
par la suite aller en BP pour après
peut-être ouvrir mon salon et on verra
la suite c'est une vocation familiale
et ça te plaît
après j'ai toujours été forcément déçu
par les patrons mais faut pas se laisser
aller il faut faut continuer et voilà
après pour se démotiver quoi d'accord et
maintenant du coup
alors donc moi
ça a bien par ma tante qui elle aussi
est dans l'esthétique
et elle m'a trouvé je pense qu'elle m'a
transmis cette passion là et j'aime
énormément prendre soin des personnes
leur donner du bien-être qu'elle se
sentent bien dans leur peau après une
prestation esthétique et donc j'ai fait
mon CAP esthétique en deux ans le BP
également devant et maintenant je fais
mon BTS et par la suite j'aimerais bien
également faire un spam manager et après
pouvoir ouvrir mon entreprise d'accord
donc avec une vocation de devenir chef
d'entreprise
belle ambition effectivement et du coup
c'est un métier passion pour toutes les
deux j'ai bien compris et une origine
familiale alors on n'a pas forcément une
personne de la famille pour pour
commencer ce métier mais pourquoi pas
chacun un sa motivation à sa motivation
de départ alors on a une première
question comment comment s'inscrire donc
on va peut-être reprendre peut-être plus
précisément
revoir les conditions d'inscription
alors ce qu'il faut en fait de toute
façon c'est aller sur le site internet
et puis vous avez une procédure de
préinscription donc en fait sur le site
internet tout simplement la Faculté des
Métiers vous allez
c'est fait partie de vous allez sur le
la filière beauté bien-être qui est
celle qui voilà c'est une formation
et il y a marqué s'inscrire en ligne
donc vous cliquez dessus et finalement
il y aura juste à suivre le menu
déroulant avec le nom le prénom etc
certains nombre de d'éléments qui vont
vous être demandés et notamment le mail
et puis ensuite une fois que vous
validez cette préinscription en ligne on
reprend contact avec vous par mail donc
de toute façon vous serez contacté une
fois que votre inscription en ligne est
validée avec les éléments pour pouvoir
justement vous recontacter vous ou votre
responsable légal si vous n'êtes pas
majeur et on envoie un mail en fait dans
les quelques jours qui suivent votre
pré-inscription en ligne et ensuite on
va vous expliquer la marche à suivre
d'accord donc c'est relativement simple
il y aura en fait des documents pour
envoyer voilà les bulletins certains
noms d'éléments comme ça la carte
d'identité etc mais tout sera bien
expliqué dans le mail et une fois que
vous avez renvoyé ces documents là vous
êtes convient à un entretien de
préinscription voilà donc ce qu'il faut
c'est aller sur le site internet et
suivre juste suivre l'inscription en
ligne vous allez voilà valider votre
inscription et puis ensuite ça suit son
cours la seule chose qui est importante
c'est de regarder régulièrement
à l'adresse mail en fait que vous avez
indiqué lors de votre inscription en
ligne de regarder régulièrement et
notamment dans les spams
ça c'est important
elle permet de poser une question est-ce
que quels sont les critères en fait qui
font ce qu'il y a une pré-inscription ça
veut dire que est-ce que tout le monde
ne peut pas s'inscrire est-ce qu'il y a
des critères pour finaliser une
inscription
ça va être après suite à l'entretien de
recrutement en fait de toute façon c'est
on demande les bulletins et puis un
certain nombre de documents
administratifs qu'il faudra absolument
mettre à notre disposition par exemple
la carte d'identité ce genre de choses
là sinon on peut pas recevoir en
entretien
ceux d'entre vous qui n'auraient pas
effectivement tous les documents
nécessaires mais encore une fois s'il y
a des problèmes spécifiques vous avez le
numéro le mail de la personne on a vu
les noms tout à l'heure voilà on peut
s'adapter aussi il y a des
problématiques spécifiques mais sinon
vous mettez tout en ligne et
automatiquement vous recevrez en
entretien et en fait cet entretien de
motivation ça va nous permettre aussi
d'évaluer puisque c'est des métiers
vraiment passion qu'il faut avoir envie
de faire absolument
d'évaluer aussi votre motivation si par
exemple les bulletins sont pas forcément
très bon s'il y a des problématiques ou
autres là on va en discuter en fait avec
le jeune directement et puis si les
mineurs il y a le parent qui
l'accompagnera aussi et puis on va en
discuter c'est suite à cette entretien
que il y a trois choix possibles soit
votre candidature elle est retenue soit
vous pouvez être on va dire en liste
d'attentes ça peut être pour des jeunes
peut-être qu'on peut encore d'entreprise
mais on peut vous aider malgré tout à
chercher une entreprise voilà soit on
peut vous conseiller une réorientation
ce serait pour un jeune qui est pas du
tout sûr aussi ou qui hésite avec
d'autres formations donc en fait c'est
suite à cet entretien de recrutement que
votre on validera ou non en fait votre
inscription voilà
alors dans les questions que nous pose
donc des personnes qui nous regardent
quand les candidatures sont étudiées à
quel moment et là on commence les
inscriptions donc là on commence à
étudier à étudier les candidatures voilà
donc c'est au fil de l'eau en fait tout
simplement
et ça a démarré voilà n'hésitez pas à le
faire au plus tôt je pense après les
places restent limitées dans ces
sections là parce que ce qu'on a pas
indiqué c'est qu'effectivement les
conditions de pratique sont vraiment
optimum et nous avons un maximum de 14
jeunes par ateliers c'est à dire que par
classe nous avons 14 jeunes maximum
alors nous avons plusieurs groupes
évidemment que ce soit en CAP en BP on
n'a pas qu'une seule classe mais
effectivement
il faut vous inscrire dès à présent
maintenant les inscriptions se
poursuivent voilà jusqu'à la fin la fin
de l'année scolaire et si jamais il y a
encore des places ça peut être jusqu'à
la rentrée mais il est vrai que
pour ce même pour ceux qui hésitent
encore n'hésitez pas à faire des
préinscriptions ça n'a pas valeur
d'inscription définitive et vous pourrez
échanger justement même en entretien de
recrutement vous pourrez échanger avec
le formateur ou la charge est
développement si c'est que vous
rencontrez et ça pourra aussi pourquoi
pas vous conforter dans votre choix ou
en tout cas vous apporter des
informations complémentaires et surtout
venez aussi nous voir lors des porteuses
ouvertes voilà on peut avoir des jeunes
qui se sont préinscrits et qui viennent
malgré tout nous revoir aussi lors des
portes ouvertes même s'ils sont déjà
venus donc n'hésitez pas
autre question sur le rythme donc entre
la formation en CFA et donc en
entreprise est-ce que c'est une semaine
sur deux est-ce que c'est autrement
alors c'est tous c'est du 2 jours 3
jours sur l'ensemble des formations je
me retourner aussi vers les filles qui
nous accompagnent donc c'est du 2 jours
3 jours pour toutes les formations donc
le jour
en formation alors en général il me
semble que c'est deux jours en formation
trois jours en entreprise voilà
voilà tout à fait
est-ce que
vous avez une formation spécialisée en
prothèse ongulaire absolument pas non
voilà mais voilà prothésion angulaire
lors du BP Esthétique donc en Première
et en deuxième année donc on apprend
tout ce qui est bases comme la pose de
gel de résine et de capsule mais c'est
une petite partie alors que quand on
veut devenir prothésiste ongulaire ou se
spécialiser il faut faire une formation
professionnelle formation spécifique
tout à fait qui peut durer quelques
jours à plusieurs semaines tout dépend
aussi de
ce que je peux préciser en tant que
chambre de métier c'est que la formation
en prothèse angulaire et bien une
spécialité de l'esthétique et le fait de
faire une formation en prothésie
angulaire ne permet pas de s'installer à
son compte en esthétique parce qu'on a
souvent cette question ce serait comme
un procès
voilà c'est une spécialité plus mais
c'est pas tout seul ça permet pas de
s'installer un esthétique alors par
contre effectivement
avec ou sans formation
une autre question sur la rémunération
les mineurs sont-ils rémunérés ou bien
est-ce que c'est un stage donc les
mineurs sont rémunérés
alors je sais pas si on peut revoir la
il y avait une slide avec la
rémunération donc à partir de 15 ans
donc vous pouvez démarrer votre contrat
à partir de 15 ans 15 ans révolu donc à
partir du jour de votre votre
anniversaire il y a effectivement une
rémunération jusqu'à votre majorité en
fait il y a différentes tranches il y a
on va dire 15 17 ans
18-21 ans voilà jusqu'à la veille des 21
ans donc 18 ans à 20 ans 21 ans 25 ans
et ensuite plus de 26 ans vous voyez les
différentes tranches de rémunération et
de toute façon c'est niveau de salaire
sont indiqués sur votre contrat
d'apprentissage si par exemple vous
démarrez votre contrat vous avez 17 ans
et que l'année d'après vous avez 18 ans
votre rémunération va changer donc en
fait les différents niveaux de
rémunération seront indiqués à la
signature de votre contrat
d'apprentissage je sais pas quelque
chose que vous découvrirez en cours de
contrat
alors autre question sur la formation
combien de temps dure-t-elle
tout dépend des formations on a des
formations en un an et des formations 2
ans il y a le cap que ce soit sur la
coiffure ou l'esthétique qui peuvent se
faire en deux ans ou en un an si vous
êtes déjà titulaire d'un diplôme
équivalent le BP c'est en 200 c'est
quand même vers voilà la mention
complémentaire c'est une année de
spécialisation et le BTS c'est en 2 ans
et quand on commence l'enseignement
après on peut éventuellement accepter
des jeunes alors ça c'est pour les
formations d'apprentissage en général
jusqu'à voilà on peut accepter des
jeunes un petit peu au fil de l'eau
maintenant ça va dépendre s'il reste de
la place et comme je le disais en
généralement les formations ces
formations sont on va dire complète
quasi complète à la rentrée
un jeune qui doit déménager et qui
demande s'il est possible de s'inscrire
dans un CFA d'une autre région alors en
cours d'année c'est possible il faudra
voir avec le CFA concerné mais c'est
toujours possible et après bon alors si
c'est un déménagement je suppose que le
jeune ne gardera pas le même contrat
auquel cas il faudra faire une rupture
de contrat et trouver un autre contrat
mais ça il faut se renseigner avec un
autre avec le CFA qui vous intéresse
sera encore une fois c'est lui c'est lui
qui sera qui pourra vous refuser ou
accepter la candidature
alors une question spécifique sur la
Faculté des Métiers des sols
possède-t-elle un internat
non nous n'avons pas l'internat vous
possibilité peut-être de se loger autour
mais il n'y a pas d'information
spécifiquement
alors
je pense qu'on a répondu pour l'instant
en question que vous nous aviez vous
nous aviez posé moi j'aurais une petite
question qui revient assez souvent chez
les jeunes qui cherchent à devenir
apprenti c'est comment comment on trouve
l'entreprise parce que on a bien vu par
rapport à l'école toute la manière qu'il
faut adopter pour s'inscrire avec donc
envoyer effectivement une candidature
etc mais il y a aussi le volet
entreprise donc un apprentissage va
impliquer que vous ayez un employeur je
m'adresse toutes les deux comment vous
avez trouvé votre première employeur
alors donc moi j'ai fait appel à Madame
Fournol
parce qu'au début donc
j'avais une entreprise sur qu'elle m'a
lâché et j'étais vraiment à cours d'idée
pour avoir un employeur et donc j'ai
fait appel à Madame Fournel qui a très
bien tu me dirigé et j'ai trouvé
directement mon entreprise donc
le premier contact c'était la première
entreprise c'est toi qui l'avais trouvé
directement oui parce qu'on donc en 3e
j'ai fait mon stage là dans cette
entreprise et elle a bien voulu prendre
un contrat d'apprentissage et puis ça
arrive que finalement
ça change et du coup le intervenir mais
c'est vrai que on demande toujours
malgré tout à ce que chaque jeune puisse
chercher oui c'est important puis ça
montre aussi votre motivation par
rapport à votre projet c'est à dire que
même si évidemment le CFA va vous aider
vous l'avez vu voilà concrètement
effectivement l'être qu'on peut apporter
mais c'est important aussi que les
jeunes cherchent de leur côté et puis
très sincèrement quand c'est vous qui
trouvez tout seul votre entreprise c'est
extrêmement gratifiant donc il y a aussi
une grosse satisfaction déjà qui
arrivent ils ont trouvé voilà donc
faites-le même si c'est pas facile la
première fois de pousser la porte d'un
employeur comment ça s'est passé pour
toi pour ma part pareil mon premier
salon j'ai cherché et du coup bah j'ai
trouvé grâce à mon stage de 3e et mon
deuxième salon du coup j'ai demandé à
Madame Fournol et après de mon côté j'ai
cherché et j'ai pu trouver à 10 minutes
de chez moi
c'est vrai que la proximité à son
importance parce que ça élimine un
premier souci comme vous l'avez vu
arriver à l'heure et c'est vrai que
remarqué on dit toujours que quand on
habite à côté on est encore plus en
retard mais enfin au moins on a le sang
quoi voilà mais encore au moins c'est
quand même plus facile
voir aller travailler à côté à côté de
chez soi même si c'est pas évidemment le
seul critère de sorte de terre de choix
de votre employeur
est-ce que toutes les deux vous auriez
des conseils à donner aux jeunes qui
veulent qui veulent se lancer qu'est-ce
qui quels sont les points en fait que
vous avez trouvé de j'ai envie de dire
de positif et puis les quelques points
de vigilance aussi
montrer sa motivation ne pas être
découragé dès qu'un employeur
refuse de nous prendre en apprentissage
continuer de chercher faut s'accrocher
et
puis après être motivé c'est à dire que
préparer quelques arguments en fait
parce que je dis je suis motivée oui ne
pas arriver comme ça devant l'employeur
sans avoir de réfléchir un petit peu
avant on va forcément vous poser des
questions de vos motivation donc donner
deux trois arguments qui vont pas
correspondre en vacances
moi je rajouterais peut-être une petite
chose
les filles en plus c'est ayez aussi une
présentation extrêmement soignée je vous
laisse peut-être compléter
être professionnel de pas arriver en
jean troué
coiffer à l'arrache avec présentable
de CV ou une lettre de motivation ou
dire je suis passé il y a un mois
relancer relancer parce que des fois ça
fonctionne bien parce que à force de
vous voir on se dit bah tiens cette
jeune là elle est motivée et mais par
contre éviter le téléphone déplacez vous
vraiment on a vraiment besoin de voir
de vous voir en fait dans votre métier
moi j'en profite pour rebondir sur ce
que dit donc Madame salut je suis
d'accord sur le téléphone mais je
conseille quand même d'appeler toutes
les entreprises dans le coin pour faire
une pré-sélection dans le sens où vous
appelez l'entreprise et vous dites
bonjour je voudrais savoir si vous
prenez un contrat d'apprentissage pour
l'année prochaine et si on vous dit oui
là vous pouvez demander à quel moment
vous vous déplacez pour bien sûr vous
présenter et déposer lettre de
motivation et CV même si c'est minime et
vous présenter de vive voix c'est juste
faire voilà une première sélection pour
pas déposer des lunettes de motivation
et CV dans des entreprises qui ne
prennent pas de contrat d'apprentissage
sinon je rejoins sur saint-macl
donc en fait pousser la porte c'est
quand même se présenter se présenter et
être bien soigné
plus dans les filières de la beauté ça
paraît ça paraît une évidence mais les
évidences sont toujours mieux dit quand
même alors on a une question sur la
possibilité d'intégrer la filière ou pas
en cours d'année par exemple maintenant
ou est-ce qu'il faut attendre la rentrée
là maintenant c'est tard parce qu'en
fait il faut vraiment aussi ne pas avoir
accumulé trop de retard alors je peux
pas dire non d'une manière définitive
mais là pour l'instant ça n'arrive pas
et puis même on n'a pas de demande ça
peut être un déménagement par exemple
donc un jeune qui aurait peut-être déjà
suivi le début de la formation ailleurs
où là on peut étudier la candidature si
nous avons de la place sinon néanmoins
là ça reste là c'est un peu tardif
apparemment patience quand même enfin
toujours tenté d'autant plus je rajoute
sur les formations en un an ou de toute
façon on fait les inscriptions à
l'examen et en décembre les inscriptions
sont clôturées donc après les
inscriptions c'est sûr qu'on prend pas
le jeune
est-ce que l'inscription à la filière
nécessite une CV et une lettre de
motivation c'est à l'école qu'on a
répondu oui oui alors après je pense que
c'est demandé dans le à un moment de la
préinscription mais si le CV n'est pas
très bien fait ce n'est pas grave
derrière on va vous aider à le faire
mais néanmoins ça peut être demandé dans
les documents de préinscription et puis
la lettre de motivation c'est normal
mais ça va être la lettre de motivation
pour vous inscrire par contre au CFA
c'est pas forcément la lettre de
motivation que vous ferez pour
l'employeur
est-ce qu'on peut aider les jeunes à
faire leurs lettres de motivation parce
que c'est pas si simple alors je pense
que le CV il y a plein de modèles
partout
et de par quand on est en troisième donc
il y a énormément de choses alors il y a
il faut toujours valoriser ce qu'on fait
même en
sport de l'école mais je pense que le CV
pose-moi le souci que la lettre de
motivation parce que c'est sûr que tout
le monde va prendre les lettres de
motivation en modèle sur Internet s'ils
ont tous la même lettre de motivation ça
doit pas être très très motivant pour
l'employeur donc est-ce qu'il y a des
est-ce qu'il y a une aide peut-être de
toute façon il y a une aide globale qui
est apportée pour la recherche
d'entreprise et notamment il y a des
ateliers qui sont mis en place très
régulièrement jusqu'à la jusqu'à la fin
de l'année et dans ces ateliers il y a
pas que CV bien évidemment il y a aussi
les lettres de motivation il y a
l'entretien préparer son entretien donc
ça ça s'est vu en fait dans le cadre de
ces ateliers ou sinon après c'est avec
le chargé de développement dans le cas
de la recherche de la recherche
d'entreprise je pense qu'on peut
insister là dessus ne pas hésiter
justement à participer à ces ateliers
parce que quand on recherche un
employeur pour la première fois sûrement
une certaine timidité qui est tout à
fait naturelle et normale il faut aller
au-delà de cette timidité pour pouvoir
se mettre en valeur
c'est pas c'est pas simple se mettre de
se mettre en valeur sans savoir lire ton
compréhension non plus enfin l'équilibre
pour que
l'employeur puisse vous embaucher
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
alors il y a d'autres questions donc
j'avais j'attends qu'on nous les conduit
les apporte en attendant ces questions
est-ce que vous auriez un petit mot
adressé donc aux jeunes qui qui vous
regardent qui leur donneraient envie
juste si vous voulez
en apprentissage
quelle est la différence entre le
contrat professionnel et le contrat
d'apprentissage peut-être la question
alors déjà c'est par rapport aux
conditions parce que le contrat
d'apprentissage on fait en signer
jusqu'à 29 ans révolu et en fait au delà
puisqu'on a aussi beaucoup d'adultes
évidemment qui vont dans ces formations
là des métiers voter bien-être et de
l'artisanat en général puisque on peut
avoir des rencontres régulièrement on a
des reconversions professionnelles et
dans ces cas-là au-delà de 29 ans ça va
être un contrat professionnel il n'y a
pas de contrat d'apprentissage qui est
possible donc en fait c'est surtout ça
et puis après je vous dirais que ça
c'est plutôt à l'employeur qui décide
sinon quand il y a la possibilité de
faire les deux types de contrats ça va
être les employeurs qui décident si
c'est du contrat professionnels du
contrat d'apprentissage dans les petites
entreprises qui sont 95 de nos
entreprises ça va être du contrat
d'apprentissage parce que pour eux
financièrement c'est plus intéressant
tout simplement donc en fait de toute
façon c'est pas le jeûne qui va décider
c'est l'entreprise qui décide du type de
contrat la seule chose qu'il faut savoir
pour vous c'est que par rapport à votre
formation ça ne changera rien c'est à
dire de toute façon dans la même place
il peut y avoir peut-être un jeune en
contrat pro je vous dis on a peu de
contrats pro c'est aussi ça va être sauf
si c'est des adultes en général et des
jeunes en contrat d'apprentissage donc
là pour vous peu importe et c'est pas
vous qui déciderez finalement c'est
l'employeur et ce qui va décider c'est
tout ce qui va être financier pour lui
donc en général les petites entreprises
c'est plus intéressant d'avoir un
contrat d'apprentissage donc elles vont
choisir un contrat d'apprentissage pour
vous les jeunes ça change rien vous êtes
dans les mêmes classes vous avez le même
temps de travail et autres donc pas
d'inquiétude
une petite question par rapport au BTS
Esthétique en fait quelles sont les
particularités de ce de ce BTS par
rapport à un brevet professionnel
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on apprend de
spécifique en fait après les brevets
professionnels pour avoir le BTS alors
ces deux diplômes là ont une approche
différente c'est vrai que j'aime bien
donner cet exemple le cap donc c'est le
diplôme de base le Brevet Professionnel
donc c'est une spécialisation surtout
dans tout ce qui est soin du corps on se
spécialise dans le métier et le BP on va
dire qu'il est à peu près deux fois plus
dur que le cap le BTS lui va être deux
fois plus dur que le bébé mais si une
autre approche en fait c'est pas un
niveau qui est très scolaire c'est
surtout on va beaucoup être dans la dans
la recherche dans la dans la synthèse
dans l'analyse
du métier donc après les débouchés sont
complètement différents que quand on
fait un BTS généralement c'est pas juste
pour être esthéticienne c'est parce
qu'on a envie de dire soit de diriger
une équipe par exemple Manon qui veut
être spamanager
ou d'être formatrice professeur ou de
travailler dans des laboratoires etc
donc c'est une approche qui est vraiment
différente et qui sort du cadre assez
scolaire c'est pour ça que c'est assez
difficile parce qu'on est habitué depuis
qu'on est jeune à prendre tout
simplement une leçon et après de la
comment de le dire
de la reproduire excusez-moi alors que
là c'est une approche qui est différente
c'est pour ça que c'est d'autant plus
difficile mais très intéressant à
condition d'avoir les ambitions pour
merci à une autre une autre question qui
nous arrive
alors je suis actuellement en troisième
aurais-je donc un contrat
d'apprentissage ou professionnalisation
contrat d'apprentissage ça c'est sûr
bon donc vous avez compris que le
contrat de professionnalisation ou le
contrat d'apprentissage le choix revient
avant tout à l'employeur donc vous ce
qui est important c'est de vous dire je
suis prêt à faire une formation en
alternance en fait après le contrat
lui-même est plutôt économique on va
dire et c'était l'employeur qui va vous
proposer un apprentissage ou une
professionnalisation alors notre
conférence arrive à arrive à son terme
donc n'hésitez surtout pas à vous rendre
journée portes ouvertes je pense que
c'est un excellent complément de
notre première sûrement de votre
première j'ai envie de dire
visite virtuelle du CFA pour les métiers
de la beauté donc coiffure et esthétique
on remercie vivement les participants
qui j'espère ont pu répondre maximum à
vos questions donc maintenant à vous de
jouer de vous rendre aux journées portes
ouvertes de peut-être déjà
éventuellement voir des entreprises qui
pourraient vous accueillir si vous êtes
si vous êtes décidé à rentrer dans cette
toute type de formation à partir de la
rentrée prochaine on vous souhaite une
excellente journée et à très bientôt au
revoir au revoir